it's the fifth of June I'm not just
McDonald and the Americans have taken
over gamespot news there are many xbox
one things happened today one of which
is that you can now use an xbox one
controller with your PC and that's great
for pc games that are kind of a pain
with a keyboard dark souls the pc
drivers can be grabbed right now through
links fung major nelson's blog but will
also be widely distributed in a future
windows update microsoft said in a
statement we know our fans wanted pc
compatibility and we know they wanted to
be able to use the xbox one controller
with the same games and applications
have been playing with using the xbox
360 controller you'll be able to use the
xbox one controller with any gamepad
supported game that works with the 360
controller let me know your respective
levels of excite it seems we may have
inadvertently snag ourselves one of
Sony's e3 reveals a little early since
amazon france have revealed a ps4 and PS
vita bundle the bundle is called the
ultimate players edition and if
presently unannounced the amazon product
page indicated that the bundle will go
on sale on july 4th for 570 euros which
is about 790 American bucks let me know
in that comment box what you think of
the price and if you're at all
interested in the bundle according to
Microsoft the xbox one will be getting
more GPU power as a result of the
system's new update microsoft Phil
Spencer has said on Twitter during Xbox
one software dev kit gives dense access
to more GPU bandwidth more performance
new tools and flexibility to make games
better what are the suspected reasons
that things are set to get better for
Xbox one is as a result of the Kinect
being detached which was rumored to use
ten percent of the consoles graphics
resources lastly CD Projekt RED held at
which the three purchased live stream
today and here's what you probably want
to know about from our favorite
Europeans yo to favor Europeans
Stevie Projekt RED announced at the
witcher 3 wild hunt will be coming on
the twenty-fourth of babri and they
revealed a snazzy new trailer for the
RPG we meet Jennifer girls long-lost
love as well as his sort of adopted
daughter for all the super cool graphics
and epic scenes of epic epicness be sure
to check out the trailer on gamespot be
sure let me know down there in that
commit book what'd you think of the
witcher 3 and what you want to see it to
live on specifically that is it for me
today but tomorrow I'll be back with my
top 5 show where we'll have an extra
special surprise so be sure to tune into
the bat